today we're talking about what you can
expect from Modern Warfare 2's
multiplayer at launch
the full release of Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 was right around the corner
and Activision has now detailed
everything players can expect from The
Game's multiplayer Suite come launch day
currently players who pre-order Modern
Warfare 2 can get early access to the
game's single player campaign
multiplayer will arrive for all players
on October 28th though those wanting to
experience Warzone 2.0 will have to wait
a little bit longer as the free-to-play
Battle Royale isn't arriving until
November 16th modes in Modern Warfare 2
are broken down into two categories core
map modes and battle map modes core map
modes are smaller 6v6 combat zones that
players familiar with the series are no
doubt accustomed to battle map modes
however are built for 32 v32 game types
and include Vehicles some of the core
map modes you can expect to see are Team
Deathmatch domination hardpoint and
control there are nine in total but I
figured I'd just read my favorite ones
the battle map modes consist of ground
war and ground war invasion the playlist
available at launch are featured quick
play third person and Tier 1 formerly
known as hardcore Activision has not
officially revealed the number or names
of the maps that will be included at
launch but its recent blog post does
clarify that Maps will come in three
different flavors there will be Maps
based on the Middle Eastern themed Al
mazura region which also serves as the
main map for Warzone 2.0 the Central
America region Los Alamos which is
featured prominently in the Modern
Warfare 2 campaign and maps that take
place in the quote rest of the world as
Activision Blizzard puts it let me know
in the comments if you've already beaten
the campaign but don't spoil anything or
I'll invade your kitchen and eat all
your snacks and sticking with the
multiplayer news a recent job listing at
naughty dog might be pointing towards
the Untitled Last of Us multiplayer
title being free to play as spotted by
Reddit user jaded Darkness shared to the
gaming lease and rumor subreddit a live
Ops producer role posted by Naughty Dog
seems to suggest the Studio's
multiplayer Last of Us game might be
free to play in the bonus skill section
one of the points listed reads proven
experience in a production role
supporting a triple A free-to-play Live
title naughty dog hasn't announced a
free-to-play title but last year the
studio was looking for an economy
designer for a multiplayer game with
live service Elements which was prior to
the official reveal that The Last of Us
multiplayer game would be a standalone
title considering Sony has plans to
launch 12 live service games by 2025 a
free-to-play multiplayer last of us
would fit quite nicely in there not much
is known about the unnamed multiplayer
game other than a potential San
Francisco setting but more details were
promised to be coming next year a
free-to-play Last of Us game definitely
wasn't on my bingo card but let me know
in the comments what you think and if
you're excited for the possibility
foreign